both nato and russia have eyes on this
swedish island once inhabited by vikings
in as early as the 8th century this
piece of land is of strategic importance
that's because it's located in the
center of the baltic sea and is on
nato's european front line
but it's also the only waterway where
russia has direct access to the west
gotland is just one small part of how
nato could benefit if sweden and finland
become members of the bloc
both nations have said they will take
steps to apply for membership of the
western military alliance
it is very significant shift these are
two countries that have sought to take a
position of military non-alignment
finnish and swedish membership in nato
would greatly enhance the defense of the
baltic region and reduce the chances of
russian adventurism or attack across the
air land and sea domains in an
integrated fashion analysts say the
expansion of the block could make nato
stronger and affect russia's current
strategy in ukraine to understand how we
need to look at the geography and
military capabilities of both countries
the location of both sweden and finland
would mean the alliance has
significantly more land in the east of
europe
take finland for example
it has an 830 mile long border with
russia but if we look a little closer we
can see that this border is full of
lakes and marshland with very few roads
for military vehicles such as tanks to
travel on
analysts say those conditions would be
beneficial for nato in any potential
combat situation with russia
from a nato point of view it's a huge
opportunity so you think about combat in
ukraine over by kiev where russia was
trying to push down really narrow roads
that's finland
one key area for russia is the kola
peninsula where moscow houses
sub-launched ballistic missiles that are
key to its nuclear arsenal
currently the only nato country
bordering the zone is norway but
analysts say if finland joins the block
it would increase pressure on the region
so suddenly if finland's having an
exercise up here it's not just norwegian
forces you know maybe a brigade or two
now suddenly it might be 50 000 troops
so again russia has to now divert troops
up there in sweden gotland is strategic
for russia because it could be a base to
protect its naval forces in the baltic
sea
they would
use that as a base of operations for
amphibious assault for land attack for
air attack and for naval attack
in 2017 nato and sweden worked together
on a simulated mission of a baltic sea
attack which albert said concluded the
island would be a central part of any
invading strategy
although finland and sweden have been
close nato partners for decades and
worked on such joint missions they have
remained militarily non-aligned
for centuries sweden has largely avoided
involvement in military conflicts while
finland stayed out of nato after the
alliance formed in 1949 largely to avoid
provoking russia
so the fact that they are deciding
now to potentially join the alliance i
think is very significant and speaks to
the sense of vulnerability
that countries feel in the wake of
russia's invasion of ukraine russia's
invasions of georgia in 2008 and crimea
in 2014 sounded alarm bells in both
nations but the current war pushed them
to reconsider nato membership
in response russia which has long stood
against any eastward expansion of the
block has issued threats
according to the kremlin russian
president vladimir putin told the
finnish president that ending the
country's decades-long non-aligned
defense policy would be a mistake for
helsinki
and russian deputy foreign minister
alexander grushko said that moscow would
need to take adequate precautionary
measures if nato were to deploy
infrastructure for nuclear weapons near
russia's borders including in finland i
think one of the reasons that we've see
we saw um the invasion of ukraine is
because they are not a member of nato
and
that you know russia felt that they
could therefore
take the action they did without
incurring a direct
response from nato and so i think
that is something that will be playing
into moscow's um strategic calculus that
once these states are
if they become members of nato
then it will have to take
a more indirect action the addition of
finland and sweden to nato would also
enhance some of the bloc's shortfalls in
air defense according to al burke
they do not have sufficient vehicle
mounted air defense systems
nato air defenses especially in the east
are very very weak and again this is a
huge capability shortfall that nato is
attempting to address
sweden's advanced purchases of air
launch cruise missiles and finland's 9.4
billion purchase of 64 cutting-edge
usf-35 fighter jets would significantly
improve nato's air defense and attack
capabilities
and it could require russia to add
counter measures to that potential
threat analysts say spreading its
resources thin while trying to establish
air dominance
but some analysts also believe that the
introduction of sweden and finland into
the block could fit into a broader plan
by russian president vladimir putin to
realign his forces to different regions
i think russia
thought a long time ago that finland and
sweden would end up joining nato i think
it helps putin in terms of his messaging
that nato is scary
so that he can divert resources from
human development in russia towards
military